I continue to believe that the people
who are currently supporting Donald
Trump are a lost cause and we are going
to look at some examples Donald Trump
holding this event yesterday in
Davenport Iowa sort of like his first
major campaign event supposedly a a
speech about education very little about
education was discussed right side
broadcasting network was there they
interviewed people waiting in line here
is a guy who explains what he learned
from Tucker Carlson's program over the
last week about the Trump riots this I
hope you're sitting down for this well
let's just keep let's keep that up
the people that really did the damage
workers Abraham
there you go what this guy learned from
Tucker's show is that the real Trump
rioters were not Trump supporters they
were antifa antifa folks
what what a stupid country we live in I
mean it's just it's gotten humiliatingly
bad here it really really is bad and it
only gets worse I hate to tell you in
these interviews here's a woman
interviewed at a trump rally who says
when Trump was President she didn't have
to worry about the state of the
direction of the world everything Music
Entertainment Sports pop culture
everything I mean everything yeah yeah
everything the left touches it destroys
yep I'm glad you guys are here yeah
feeling that you had when Trump was
there that you don't have to worry about
where the world
yeah
there it is when Trump was President she
didn't have to worry she just she was
worry-free here is a woman who says that
Trump is the king of the world clearly
to some degree misunderstanding how our
political system works see the people
The Comeback tour now Trump is King in
Iowa exactly he's King everywhere he's a
king everywhere over the world yeah the
very same people who are afraid of a new
world order one world government are uh
cheering Trump as king of the world when
asked which traits about Trump folks in
the crowd most missed the most
frequently cited was Trump's honesty and
truthfulness as you can remember that
was not the case uh what do you miss the
most about President Trump
yeah
yeah yeah
really cares about America he truly
cares about Americans obviously he
doesn't and he was really truthful and
honest he wasn't one guy walking into
the rally had some Choice words for
right side broadcasting to our
newsletter
rsbnetwork.com slash newsletter by the
yo don't do that no it is and of
course the rallying Cry of the low
information Midwest Trump supporter a
grabber by the you know what
um the topic of Ron Des Sanctus came up
and one woman says the reason she would
not support Des Sanctus is because he's
funded by George Soros which is an
interesting combination of conspiracies
is anybody talking about any other
person for president other than Donald J
Trump any other name
yeah
no no no no yeah Sorrows money Source
money yeah there it is yeah uh DeSantis
is bad because he's funded by uh George
Soros famously uh unknown to anyone but
apparently that's the case
um here's one other uh person weighing
in about Ron DeSantis and the
possibility of DeSantis rather than
Trump but have you heard anybody else
talk about any other candidate the
scientist yeah is that he's the only one
do you think he has big support here
I I feel like it could go either way to
Santa Trump because Trump's vilified and
DeSantis knows how to talk to the Mania
so I can see it going either way
interesting so this political analyst
believes that it really could go one way
or the other just a couple more of these
here's another guy very proudly saying
that he misses Trump's honesty
um biggest things you miss about
President Trump
the frankness be honesty on frankness
and the honesty are the real traits that
this gentleman is missing and then
lastly here is another woman asked what
do you want Trump to do about education
what are you looking forward to to
either sing and hear it from the
president today
yeah in terms of Education what would
you like to see him change or improve or
suggest um enforce God and patriotism
and force God
put enforce God and patriotism back into
the schools so the folks who chose to go
to this event
Miss Trump's honesty and truthfulness
believe antifa
did
did January 6th and want God forced back
into the schools this is what we're up
against these are people who are not
going to go for Nikki Haley
these are people who are not going to go
for Rhonda Sanctus
these are Trump people through and
through and what we can hope is that
somehow Trump loses the primary
runs as an independent
brings these people with them
splits the Republican vote and
guarantees Democratic victory in 2024.
we'll have all these clips on our
Instagram as well as on Tick Tock as
well as on Facebook and of course on
YouTube too
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
switch to real paper you'll get thirty
percent off your first order plus free
shipping go to realpaper.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below